Wow, this looks like a great party.
Yeah, definitely.  Oh,  do you think we should have brought some wine with us?
Anna?
Anna?  Hey, did you guys see where Anna went?
Right next to me?
Okay, that's real mature.
All right guys, I'm taking off.
Oh, I thought you already left.
Yeah, didn't you say good-bye already?
Ugh, I just keep getting pulled back in.
Okay!  I am taking off!
Hey, do it already!
You know what?  Get out then!
Hustle up!
I'm just saying good-bye.
Get a move on!
Said it too many times, girl!
Too many times, girl!
Hey, hey I gotta go.
Oh, you're leaving?
Yeah, so sorry, I gotta take off.
Hey everyone!  Anna is leaving my party early like a little biotch.
*jeering in unison*
Anna, is everything okay?
Uh, no I think I'm going to go home.
The cookies must have been bad or something.
Oh my--
No, no no no!  Don't eat that!
Don't eat the cookies everybody!  They're making Anna shit her pants!
Anna, can I get you another beer?
No, I think I'm going to head home.
What?  You just got here!
Good-bye Ethan!  Good-bye!
Oh my God.  What is happening?
Excuse me.  Excuse me, can I have your attention please!
Uh, I regret to inform you that I do indeed
have another commitment that I must attend to shortly.
However, I do look forward to being with all of you for however long
I can stay at these joyous festivities.
Anna!  Anna!
I'm sorry, there are no questions at this time.
Thank you.
Resume!
*gasps*  I think someone stole your wallet!
Someone who?
I'm going to get him!
Get out of the way!
My wallet is right here though...
C'mon, don't leave.
Yeah, we were just about to take some Tequila shots!
I'm leaving this party!
*cocks gun*
Okay!?
Anna you don't gotta do this--
Shut up Kyle!
I have to be up at 9:30 tomorrow morning.
Same here.
It's not that early.
I can't party anymore.
I think she stole my wallet.
You just got here.
Good-bye Ethan!
Ghost!
Ahhhh!
Shit.